i don't want to spend a ton of time on
this but joe rogan seems to sort of have
crossed the rubicon in some sense where
joe rogan has always been interested in
conspiracy theories i also am interested
in them joe rogan seems to believe in
more than i do but there's a difference
in what i'm going to play for you today
and something like the moon landing was
faked joe rogan's new idea is that there
is a concerted effort to restrict access
to monoclonal antibodies so that people
will get vaccinated so that big pharma
will make money i'm going to explain to
you why this makes no sense but this is
now over the line into something that is
truly quite dangerous here's the thing
i'm going to say this because it's
[ __ ] true because i've experienced it
many many times with many people that
i'm friends with they're withholding
monoclonal antibodies they're trying to
stop people from getting them there's
not a [ __ ] shortage of monoclonal
energy so what does that do monoclonal
antibodies
kills covid like raid kills roaches
when you get shot
after you get you get covered then you
get this that's what they gave trump and
that's what they gave me
i got i got better quick
i got better [ __ ] quick and trump got
better pretty quick pretty quick and
he's old and fast
he's always fat and he got better in
four days so why are they withholding it
because they want you to get vaccinated
that's what i think i think they don't
want there to be a very clear path
where you don't have to be vaccinated
but if you get sick you're gonna be fine
so so or is it just the money going into
the pharmaceutical companies that's
driving people to want everyone to get
vaccinated or must have an influence
it's also the narrative there's also
people that have been vaccinated that
don't want people to get away without
being vaccinated because i think they
know they took a chance i think secretly
they know like if anybody pays any
attention they know someone who's had a
bad reaction to the vaccine so this this
really is wacky um let's go through it
piece by piece right so first joe rogan
says there's an artificial shortage of
the monoclonal antibodies
if you research how the vaccines are
made and how the monoclonal antibodies
are made
right now
there is a much more limited ability to
generate monoclonal antibodies for the
same number of people as vaccine doses
have been made that's just a fact of
production so that the first thing is
that there's an artificial shortage
there is simply not the availability
because of the production process for
monoclonal antibodies versus vaccines
widely documented this stuff is all out
in the open you can find it then he says
the monoclonal antibodies have ev it
just you just you just get rid of covet
it just cures you we have
randomized control trials with
monoclonal antibodies they are
efficacious
it is not a silver bullet
it is not a silver bullet and if you are
in a situation where you need monoclonal
antibodies you are far better off being
vaccinated so understand that the two
first claims there's an artificial
shortage demonstrably untrue it simply
kills kovid not true it's effective it's
an effective treatment okay
also by the way
then he goes into the financial he says
there's a financial it must be jocko
says what's the point here why
it's fine is it financial and rogan says
it must be
the vaccines are made by far
pharmaceutical companies which make
money from from vaccines
the monoclonal antibodies are made by
pharmaceutical companies that make money
from monoclonal antibodies the sa you
can't ascribe a profit motive to one and
not the other
it's for-profit
pharmaceutical companies making both
so it's a wacky claim to make and in
addition to that
the vaccine the pfizer vaccine is now
fully approved by the fda the monoclonal
antibodies are authorized for emergency
use when when we say well we don't know
we really i mean if you want to make
that case we now know more from a from a
regulatory standpoint
about the pfizer vaccine than the
monoclonal antibodies but that is
missing and then lastly
you know everybody
vaccinated people want the unvaccinated
to get a vaccine
because they want others to take a risk
the way they that is crazy
that is crazy
there is no evidence of that whatsoever
and everyone knows someone who's had a
bad reaction i don't know anyone who's
had a bad reaction
um
i mean i know people who were flu-like
for 24 hours i was
um
my girlfriend's arm got red for a little
while
for like eight hours or something like
that
i don't i don't know anybody who's had
really a bad so it's it's so silly and
unfortunately it's going over a line
into something that now is getting much
more dangerous than
you know jfk
or or or flat earth or not that not that
rogan believes all this stuff but
some of this stuff is more benign
um this this is very much not
the only streaming service that
specializes in documentaries is
curiosity stream and you can get
curiosity stream one of our sponsors for
just 15 bucks a year when you use my
link below this will give you access to
the world's best selection of
documentary films there's always
so many that you can't get on netflix
hulu or amazon
i just finished watching a tremendous
film the ceo of sinaloa sinaloa a region
of mexico it's about el chapo
fascinating fascinating curiosity stream
is a must-have
if you love documentaries they always
have the best and newest titles they're
always adding new things to the library
and you can watch on all of your devices
they've got documentaries on every topic
you can imagine curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off a subscription
making it just 15 bucks a month go to
curiositystream.com
pacman the link is down below